m
et à propos de venise je vous le disais
tout à l'heure un ovni est au centre du
prochain film de louis de funès enfin de
jean giroud avec louis de funès villeray
carmes est un ovni qui nous amène sur
terre un petit homme vert qui décidément
aime beaucoup la soupe aux choux
d'où le titre du film attendant la
sortie de ce film pour le mois de
novembre
louis de funès a profité du dernier
week-end prend les rencontrer une partie
de ses spectateurs les jeunes au salon
de l'enfance occasion pour lui de
bavarder avec une partie importante de
son public et de répondre aux questions
que se posent les jeunes sur louis de
funès et qui lui posent à lui ce
monsieur les finesses croyez-vous aux
ovnis
vous pratiquer ce métier c'est tellement
ça fait déjà 35 ans je ne l'aurais pas
quoi je ne sais pas j'ai dû tourner dans
deux cents films et j'ai fait des films
bonjour et une porte et je leur permets
de sète où ils défendent leur fermait
pas c'est tout alors j'avais un jour à
faire une de nos affaires c'est ça ça a
duré longtemps
est-ce que c'est difficile de faire ma
fille oui c'est très difficile de suivre
au moins 70 à 80 ou 100 techniciens qui
sont autour de la caméra les ouvriers
c'est très très difficile
ça j'en sais rien je n'ai pas essayé la
pays
messieurs de plus de finesse vous aussi
commis dans la vie que sur l'écran pas
du tout c'est pas drôle du tout est
pareil c'est pas drôle du tout
est-ce que c'est dur de se mettre dans
la peau d'un personnage
ça dépend de quel personnage
solide à sochaux nous a pas été
difficile ça paraît simple mais c'est
difficile à jouer parce qu'une passion
là on a tourné pendant quatre semaines
et depuis j'ai appris à marcher en
sabots et c'est très difficile et sur
des gros cailloux comme ça s'il arrivait
à courir dessus petit sabot sinon ça n'a
plus de rapport avec le gendarme des
essaims terrestre c'est une chose un
petit peu philosophique mais qui est
vrai c'est loin le problème de deux
personnes âgées
c'est à dire moi écart mais on a à près
de 70 ans tous les deux et on a peur
d'être halde allait à l'hospice et je
vous en raconte pas plus lorsqu'il 15
ans une soupe aux choux sont difficiles
où ils sont très compliqués sont
difficiles ce sont des techniciens très
qualifiés pour le faire par ils ont pu
être soutenus que vous voyez vous allez
l'avoir maintenant vais l'avoir
maintenant elle vient de là où elle
vient du ciel et à la terry et puis dans
le film on la verra elle décolle aussi
bien entendu il y aura un autre énorme
vaisseau qui va emmener des maisons des
maisons et de la terre avec un hectare
de terre
on espère
[Musique]
et